we begin in china where large swathes of
hanan province are under water after
being
pummeled by torrential rain weather
forecasters say it is the heaviest
downpour in 1 000 years
at least 12 people were killed in the
provincial capital of zhangzhou
as hundreds were trapped in a flooded
subway line
many residents were left stranded in
schools
or at their workplace with flood waters
turning
city streets into roaring rivers
authorities have evacuated more than 100
000 people to safe zones
as china's military blasted a nearby dam
to release flood waters
threatening one of the country's most
heavily populated provinces
and let's get more we are joined by
correspondent matthias bolinger who is
standing by
for us in beijing matthias tell us you
know we've just been witnessing dramatic
pictures there
rescue efforts underway we understand to
free trapped
subway passengers what more can you tell
us
yeah this is a bit pretty much what
we've seen throughout the past
24 hours people have been trapped in
this subway
i have read some witnesses have said
that buses started running because the
electric requests came on run
in floods and that people went to the
subway instead
where they were trapped by the blood um
so far the authorities have said that 12
people have died
in downtown zhengzhou that does not
include the people who might have died
in the countryside we will
see probably the death toll of this
catastrophe
of this calamity much later
there are um concerns that
a dam might break in another city near
john joe
in the same province and
the rain is still coming down we have
seen
as much rain as usually in one year in
this region so it is pretty much one of
the
worst floods within the last few years
china is hit
by floods in the summer time regularly
but this
is worse than most of
what we've seen in the past few years
and we're seeing how bad it is i mean
you know people being um
forced into these small boats um also on
the subway line
you know having to walk through those
tunnels with with very little light
it really looks quite terrifying matias
you mentioned that
um dam which is upstream from
zhengzhou city we understand authorities
and i'm quoting here they say it could
collapse at any time
talk with us about the area the number
of residents that would be around there
and whether they might have time to
evacuate
the dam is near another major uh city
in this province or seven million
uh inhabitants city um
we have heard warnings that the dam
might collapse there seems to have
been a crack in that dam uh this is of
course
this would of course be a calamity it's
uh very
uh very hard to say now how big the area
would be that would be affected but it
could be very very severe
um a similar a major dam collapse has
not happened in the
in the past few years the worst probably
damn collapse that china has seen
happened in the
1970s at that time 300 000 people are
said to have
died china has 100 000 dams almost 100
000 dams and many of them are more than
40 years old
are not in a very good condition so
this would really spell a disaster that
that
we have not seen in the past year
dw correspondent matthias bollinger
following the situation
on the ground matthias we'll we'll
continue to check in with you
over the next hours thanks for bringing
us up to date
you